let's say that we have a cardboard a
sheet of cardboard that is 20 inches by
30 inches let me draw the cardboard as
neatly as I can so it might look
something like that so that is my sheet
of cardboard and just to make sure we
know the dimensions a day it's 20 inches
by 30 inches and what we're going to do
is cut out the corners of this cardboard
and all the cut out the corners are
going to be squares and we're going to
cut out an x by x corner from each from
each of the corners from each of the
corners of this piece of cardboard x by
x over here X by X and then over here X
by X and what we'll do is after we cut
out those corners we can essentially
fold down the flaps let me draw the
flaps so you can imagine we can fold
right there we could fold right there we
could fold right there and we would form
a box I guess you could you could
imagine a box without a bottom to it or
you could view a box without a top to it
so if we were to fold everything up we
would get a container that looks
something like this let me write my best
attempt to draw it so it would look like
this it would look like this this is one
flap fold folded up you can imagine this
flap right over here if I were to fold
it up like that it now would look like
this it would now look like this the
height of the flap is X so this distance
right over here is X and then if I were
to fold this flap if I were to let me do
that a little bit neater if I were to
fold this flap right over here if I were
to fold that up then it would look like
this it would look like this my best
attempt to draw it so it would look like
that and then I would fold that back
flap up so the back flap would look
something like that that would be the
back flap it would look something like
that and then this flap over here would
if I
hold it up would look something like
would look something like that and then
of course my base of my whole thing so
this whole region right over here of my
piece of cardboard would be the floor
would be the floor of this box that I'm
constructing and what I want to do is I
want to maximize the volume of this box
I want to maximize how much it can hold
and I want to maximize it by picking my
X appropriately so let's think about
what the volume of this box is as a
function of X well in order to do that
we have to forget all the dimensions of
this box as a function of X we already
know that we already know that this
corner right over here which is made up
of that when this side and this side
connect when you fold these two flaps up
that's going to be the same height over
there that's going to be the same height
over there the height of this box is
going to be X but what's the width what
is the width of this box going to be
well the width of the box is going to be
this distance right over here and this
distance is going to be 20 20 inches
minus not 1 X put minus 2 X's so this is
going to be 20 minus 2x you see it right
over here this whole distance is 20 you
subtract this X you subtract this X and
you get this distance right over here so
it's 20 minus 2x now the same logic the
same logic what is the depth of the box
what is that distance right over there
well that distance is this distance is
this distance right over here we know
that this entire distance is 30 inches
if we subtract out this X and we
subtract out this X we get the distance
that we care about so this is going to
be 30 30 minus 2x so now we have all of
the dimensions so what would the volume
be as a function of X well the volume
the volume as a function of X is going
to be equal to the height which is X the
height which is x times the width with
it which is 20 minus X 20 or sorry 20
minus 2x times the depth which
just 30 minus 2x which is 30 minus 2x
now what are possible values of X that
give us a valid volume well X can't be X
can't be less than 0 you can't make a
negative cut here somehow we would have
to add cardboard or something there so
we know that X is going to be greater
than or equal to 0 so let me write this
down X is going to be greater than or
equal to 0 and what does it have to be
less than well I can cut at most we can
see here the length right over here this
this pink color this move color is 20
minus 2x so this has got to be greater
than 0 this is always going to be
shorter than the 30 minus 2x but the 20
minus 2 X has to be greater than has to
be greater than or equal to 0 you can't
cut more cardboard than there is or you
could say that 20 has to be greater than
or equal to 2x or you could say that 10
is going to be greater than or equal to
X which is another way of saying that X
is going to be less than or equal to 10
it's a different shade of yellow X is
going to be less than or equal to 10 so
X has got to be between 0 and 10
otherwise we've cut too much or where
somehow adding cardboard or something so
first let's think about the volume at
the endpoints of this of the of our
essentially of our domain of what X can
be for our volume well our volume our
volume when X is equal to 0 is equal to
what we're going to have 0 times all of
this stuff and it's pretty obvious
you're not going to have any height here
so you're not going to have any volume
so our volume would be 0 what is our
volume when X is equal to 10 well if X
equaled 10 then was this the width here
that I've drawn in pink would be 0 so
once again we would have no volume and
this term right over here if we just
look at it algebraically would also be
equal to 0 so this whole thing would be
equal to 0 so someplace in between x
equals 0 and x equals 10 we should
achieve our maximum about our maximum
volume and before we do it analytically
with a bit of calculus let's do it
graphically so I'll get my my
d ti-85 out so let me get my ti-85 out
and so first let me set my range
appropriately before I attempt to graph
it so I'll put my graph function let me
set my range so my minimum x value let
me make that zero we know that X cannot
be less than zero my maximum x value
well ten seems pretty good my minimum my
minimum y-value this is essentially
going to be my volume I'm not going to
have negative volume so let me set that
equals zero and my maximum y-value let's
see what would be reasonable here I'm
just going to pick some a random X and
see what type of a volume I get so if X
were to be five if X were to be 5 would
be 5 times 20 minus 10 which is 10 which
so that would be did I do that right yet
fought 20 minus 2 times 5 so that would
be 10 and then times 30 minus 2 times 5
which would be 20 so it would be 5 times
10 times 20 so you'd get a volume of a
thousand cubic inches and I just
randomly pick the number 5 so let me
give my let me give my maximum y-value a
little higher than that just in case
that that isn't the maximum value I just
randomly picked so let's say Y max is
1500 and then for whatever reason our
graph doesn't fit in there then maybe we
can we can make our Y max even larger so
I think this is going to be a decent
range now let's actually input the
function itself so our volume is equal
to x times 20 minus 2x minus 2x times 30
minus 2x 30 minus 2x and that looks
about right so now I think we can graph
it so second and I want to select that
up there so I'll do graph and it looks
like we did get the right range so this
tells us volume as a function of X
between x is 0 and X is 10 and does look
like we hit a maximum point right around
there so what I'm going to do is I'm use
the trace function to figure out roughly
what that maximum point is so let me
trace this function so I can still go
high or higher okay so over there my
volume is 1050 five point five that I
can get to 1056 that I get to 1050 six
points so see this was ten fifty six
point two zero this is
10:50 6.24 then I go back to 1055 so at
least based on the level of zoom that I
have my calculator right now this is a
pretty good approximation for the
maximum value that my function actually
takes on so it looks like my maximum
value is around 10 56 and it happens at
around x equals three point eight nine
so it looks like it looks like my volume
my volume at three point eight nine is
approximately equal to one thousand and
fifty six cubic inches or you could say
that our maximum we hit a maximum when X
when X is approximately equal to
approximately equal to three point eight
nine so far we've just set up our
maximization problem then we've looked
at it graphically in the next video
we'll try to solve it analytically using
some of our calculus tools